>> THE GREATEST THING WE COULD
DO IS GET RID OF THE VIRUS
BECAUSE EVERYTHING COMES BACK TO
TOGETHER.
YOU DON’T NEED STIMULUS ONCE
THAT HAPPENS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT 3 TRILLION,
AND COULD GO TO 6 AND WE WILL
HAVE A TREMENDOUS YEAR NEXT YEAR
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE ARE DOING AND
LAYING THE SEEDS.
AINSLEY: THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT
LAST NIGHT AT THE FOX NEWS TOWN
HALL.
THEY WERE IN FRONT OF THE
LINCOLN MEMORIAL.
IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL SIGHT.
WE ALL WATCHED IT LAST NIGHT.
LET’S BRING IN HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY TO REACT
TO THAT STATEMENT, GOOD MORNING,
CONGRESSMAN.
KEVIN: GOOD MORNING, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME BACK ON.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING, DO YOU
THINK THERE SHOULD BE MORE
RELIEF?
KEVIN: YES, I DO.
I’M BACK IN WASHINGTON TODAY.
I’M WATCHING THE SENATE WORK.
I THINK THE HOUSE NEEDS TO WORK.
I’M ON A BIPARTISAN PANEL.
REPUBLICANS LAYED OUT TODAY A
PLAN, FOUR-PHASE PLAN HOW
CONGRESS CAN WORK.
WE SIT HERE AND WE LOOK AT THE
DOCTORS, THE DELIVERY DRIVERS,
DISPATCHERS, THEY ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO WORK
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC EXCEPT
CONGRESS IS NOT.
REPUBLICANS HAVE A PLAN TO GET
US BACK TO WORK AND THE FIRST
PHASE IS LET’S GET OUR
COMMITTEES BACK.
WE DON’T HAVE TO HAVE ALL OF THE
COMMITTEES AT ONCE BUT LET’S
WORK ON THE BILLS THAT ARE MOST
NEEDED.
THAT’S ABOUT FUNDING, THAT’S
ABOUT NATIONAL DEFENSE, OUR
WATER RESOURCES.
THEY CAN TAKE UP THE BIG ROOM SO
THEY HAVE THE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
THE BILLS ARE MORE NOT PARTISAN
BUT BIPARTISAN, THEY ARE NEEDED
ESSENTIAL BILLS.
ONCE WE PASS THOSE, YOU CAN
BRING CONGRESS BACK TO VOTE AND
WE CHANGE OUR VOTING STRUCTURE.
IT’S A LONGER VOTE NOT EVERYBODY
IS ON THE FLOOR AT ONCE.
WE CAN PUT FLEXY GLASS UP MUCH
LIKE GROCERY STORES IN THE AREAS
THAT ARE CONGESTED.
THESE ARE THE WAYS THAT WE CAN
MAKE CONGRESS ACTUALLY WORK
BECAUSE I BELIEVE WE ARE
ESSENTIAL INSTEAD OF STAYING
HOME.
STEVE: YEAH, WHAT DID YOU MAKE
OVER THE WEEKEND, MR. LEADER, OF
MITCH MCCONNELL AND NANCY PELOSI
PUT A LETTER TOGETHER THAT SAID
WHILE THE PRESIDENT HAD OFFERED
SOME OF THE QUICK TESTING
MACHINERY FOR CONGRESS, THEY
DECLINED IT SAYING IT SHOULD GO
TO OTHER PLACES.
WOULD THAT KIND OF -- WOULDN’T
-- I MEAN, THE USE IT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE SO EVERYBODY WHO
COMES IN CONTACT WITH THE TOP
EXECUTIVES OF THE COUNTRY, THEY
KNOW WHETHER THAT PERSON HAS IT.
DO YOU THINK MITCH AND NANCY GOT
IT RIGHT AND CONGRESS DOESN’T
NEED THAT STUFF?
KEVIN: I HAVE A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION.
AS WE OPEN UP WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED FOR ANY FLARE-UP AND
THAT’S HOW YOU DEAL WITH IT AND
HAVING A MACHINE, LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF STAFF, THE PRESS AND
OTHERS AND INSIDE THE COMMITTEE
ROOMS YOU CAN TEST, THAT’S
PROBABLY 100 MORE TESTS IN THE
PROCESS.
MAYBE IT WOULD KEEP US SAFER AND
KEEP THE ESSENTIAL WORK OF
CONGRESS GOING INSTEAD OF
STAYING HOME.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE CRITICAL
AT THE SAME TIME AND IF THERE’S
A FLARE-UP YOU MAKE SURE IT DOES
NOT CONTINUE TO GROW AND YOU
QUARANTINE THE AREA AND TRACING
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT.
BRIAN: WELL, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT,
YOU A PLAN TO GET BACK TO WORK.
THE SENATE IS BACK TO WORK.
NANCY PELOSI RAN FOR THE HILLS.
SO HOPEFULLY PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THERE’S A REASON TO BE FEARFUL
BUT THERE’S A WAY TO DO IT.
THE SAME YOU CAN GO TO CVS AND
FOOD STORE AND THERE’S WAYS TO
DO IT IN CONGRESS.
YOU’RE AN ESSENTIAL WORKER.
LET’S TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIA,
ALSO ESSENTIAL IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR LOOKS AT YOUR STATE AS
DIVERSE AS IT ACTUALLY IS, SO
MANY ARE GETTING UPSET BECAUSE
THEY ARE GETTING LUMPED IN WITH
LOS ANGELES AND DEFYING THE
LOCKDOWN ORDERS.
I HOPE I SAY THAT RIGHT, MODOC,
SUDAR AND YUBA AND DEFYING THE
GOVERNOR, WHO WILL WIN THE
STANDOFF?
KEVIN: I HOPE IT’S NOT A
STANDOFF, 40 MILLION PEOPLE, 12%
OF THE POPULATION OF THE UNITED
STATES LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT 4 STATES IN
THEMSELVES AND THERE’S AREAS
THAT HAVE DENSE POPULATION AND
SOME THAT HAVE LARGE SOCIAL
DISTANCING, THOSE COUNTIES THAT
YOU MENTIONED ARE NOT VERY
LARGE, BUT LARGE IN SIZE BUT NOT
IN POPULATION.
JUST AS THE GOVERNORS ARE MAKING
DECISIONS AND NOT THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT THEIR STATES, WE SHOULD
ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE
DECISIONS BECAUSE THEY KNOW BEST
AND THEY KNOW HOW TO MANAGE AND
DEAL WITH THAT SITUATION.
THAT’S ONE ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT
ALL FOR CALIFORNIA.
LESS WORK FOR WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND WATCH THE GOVERNOR
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT BEACHES IN
ORANGE COUNTY WHILE THE LOCALS
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO OPEN IT UP.
THEY HAD SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
IT’S WARM OUTSIDE AND THEY ARE
THE ONES WITH LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT ARE DEALING WITH THE
SITUATION.
THEY ARE BEST KNOWLEDGE ON THE
GROUND.
NOW, REMEMBER, IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A DEMOCRAT SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
THAT DEMOCRAT SPEAKER IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY IS ACTUALLY
BRINGING THEIR MEMBERS BACK THIS
WEEK.
UNFORTUNATELY IN CONGRESS WHICH
I BELIEVE IS MORE ESSENTIAL IS
NOT, BUT WE HAVE A PLAN TO BRING
PEOPLE BACK IN A SAFE MANNER
WORKING WITH PUBLIC HEALTH AND
OTHERS JUST AS I WAS IN HOME
DEPOT AND LOWES THIS WEEKEND.
I THINK CAN OPEN UP AND PUT